das ist jetzt so das klischee oberhalb
von der spitex
stützstrümpfe lecker und
zweimal vorher begleitet werden ob sie
damit die spitze geschafft keine gute
junge liste was sie drauf
[Musik]
mangelsdorf leckeres in emmerthal und
die hat nur panik wer oder was nicht
und du bist jetzt tritt tag mit spitex
burgdorf und offenburger
und showstars mit drin im leben vom
ehepaar hooligans vor wien c30 ihrem
schließlich sieht 450 jahren 1961 mittel
und groß
wir sind sie zweiter liga
sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
münster
herr immer sehr ruhig
das ist schon viel liter großer wunsch
dass die möglichst schlank reuters
zum besten team fleck
mehr user
doch heimischen pc zu der frau wohl
lieber nicht
[Musik]
einsteigen
doch dann
traf ihn
mit dem kreis kraft der programme brito
kleiner hai
zum schluss wird eine dritte
rang war es
nicht
[Musik]
noch liegt richtete sonic merkt aber mir
ein kredit für in kraft
[Musik]
robin graf zu kleinen
krankenkassen
haben also wenn du drehte nur
hauptschulen grafik bringt dann ist
derzeit so einfach für die jungs genau
wie alles jahr wirklich alleine und
spitex und das schön wenn man
damit
aber ist programm sich eigentlich
möglichst oft zu planen
[Musik]
miriam ihre klientinnen und klienten
liefern land und in der stadt die hbvf
burgdorf inne
stobbe vom
rekordschütze jedes mal mach ja eben
starten wie das stockwerk 90 aber jetzt
mal sehen und die kilometer egal wann
ihk
hast du bist weg auf schritt und tritt
überwacht
jetzt erfahre für was die blaue
überziehe schuhe sind
dass fonseka wie es ist wenn man vorher
verkürzt millimeter
kompressionsstrümpfen
hunter artist cradle of
massaker
zum opfer hier himmel
so
verbrauchten wir noch drauf
hans lang decken
als nummer zwei schließlich stehen ja
was sei gesichert durch das
wunderbar okay das ist jetzt so dass
griechische oberhalb von der spitex
war schleuniger machen oder
stützstrümpfe lecker und
putzen oder ja da wo man der spitex aber
tja was beleidigt ich das wenn du der
könig
als beleidigung fast nicht auf aber es
tut noch live image irgendwie
lustig spitex xiii und werde sehr gut
gefahren und vom gefühl her war ich
angezogen aber
später
nach richtiger bis lehrer und mit extras
der mittfünfziger und das ist schon
jetzt mit spitex immer her damit es sich
überhaupt nimmt
rates of ihr früheres der spital thusis
mittlerweile auch sehr komplex
jetzt wird
ich
danke ihm alles gute wieder
[Musik]
im auto muss miriam oder flac bricht
schriebe herrscht zeitdruck im job
und geht einfach tag war bisher zwischen
und man ist abgestürzt und der hilft
meine person und der hat mir viel ändert
aber da ist man natürlich wie möglich
und das mag so wie es dankt ist 24 meter
fertig ist das eigentlich
ja
mittags kurz stichwort miriam wo uns
selber zu burgdorf und gott wo meistens
heißt
[Musik]
miriam ich achte 20 und royal verortet
vor der spitex hat sie im inselspital
geschaffen als problem aber ich habe
einen ort
die bereits wenig klingt ja die jahre
die
irgendwie
bedarf sei da und wird nun
aber es
passiert ihm geht ja
wo sind klatschen radeln
überspitzt gesagt
was müsste passieren dass
weniger kredit theater und viele junge
leute die keine träne keyboard leer
machen mit 15
das flag fachfrau wie miriam mit 1%
350 frank rost alt über und macht seine
einfache gut finde
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dass gott
mir bisher geheißen
dann kam löffels immer mit esse zwar
schnell fertig aber mirian ich mit mir
im schlepptau
gerade ihre nächste klient warten
[Musik]
ja
der herweck müller rektor von bmi und
startete rot ist sie immer so viel leid
umgehen wie
32 maxim trankow krume bewegen
sie brauche
ich ihnen sehr wichtig auf das sie für
sich und die helfen sie uns ja ich
brauche das ich brauche
die musik und die
motte hat aber trotz auflagen wie
möglich
machen
das ist mir gott gebetet spitex zu
glauben
und wächst gar nicht methode die letzte
habe
das schild linie 7 starter fix ist
dass der stein so volksentscheid klavier
kräfte also irgendwie eines zentrums
rettung dass für sie keine option
jetzt wenn ihr jetzt auch nach kreta mit
dem jetzt zum beispiel die
aktion
minuten
raus also jetzt
ja wohl wach
wenn herbert müller und spitex nur
einmal im monat für die spritze
ja
das geht
aber sie macht alte einsame
betrieb zu beschaffen und
das wasser war goalie ty braucht man
bestimmt die zu erinnern sagt sie aber
bitte wer aber will er im mit
rettungskorb
aus
also ich wünsche ihnen alles alles gute
das sie ganz lang machen riet er selber
wohnen
schlafen ja
noch lang es immer
[Musik]
august sowie vom iran beschäftigt wie
man erschaffen welches wie man ja
einfach sagen sobald mini
[Musik]
wir wähler leben im alter und wenn wir
ihn immer wieder liebe frau bruni bis
jetzt von 3 wie viele lose
[Musik]
und wieso markt stoff mit friedhof pause
es ist in winterberg es ist irgendwie
super also dass wir die spitze schaffte
kein male gut der ist ja wieder solisten
was sie drauf stelle und ich möchte ja
du kannst
[Musik]
für mich ist oben vorstellbarer leni
zweiter im auto und so empfand sie die
regelklasse einsamkeit das sei für
gesundheit so schädlich wie ihr start in
die alkohol rauchen und übergewicht sei
also möglich mit auf das ist das ist
unerklärlich so oder es macht ihn krank
rein sondern sie ja noch darum gesetze
marlene sie galt es finger weg aus
spahns gepflegt ist für die stehen
ja
aber es geht doch hier was ich wirklich
einsam vier räume sagt mir ist
langweilig und dort wurden verlängert
lieber kaffee trinken
dabei gesellschaftliche
distanzieren und geschichten und musik
wichtig sein miriam mir klingt nacht
nicht ganz
[Musik]
neue tag neue termin ist
relativ klein
was halten verankert wissen
genau
eine ganze branche wo in steyr beliebt
er wird von seiner partnerin
flex
was du stolz machen
das ist megageil
ich darf mit kamera bliebt das
ja das sagt
frau witt reflektieren lebenspartner sie
zwei jahre
gut
wenn man das alles nicht wirke
wie wär's denn das war nix taugt
also der schmerz und angst und mundarten
[Musik]
wer will da bliebe und nimmer später
dass das ist sein wunsch dass er da
verbrämt
das ist im seeboden schulprofil ist zwar
nicht amerikas
dennoch
muss man sollte deshalb mache ich
ja schon ganz kalt aber es ist ja nicht
immer möglich ist
ein moralischer
das ist schwierig ist eine situation
nicht bis ich wünsche aber
einfacher so dass es für sie bestimmt
begegnung mit dem tod rang habe sehr
bewegt
vier leitungen gerät aber am schluss
seiner zu miriam er merkt dass es mit
ihm langsam sein
es ist ein muss im vormarsch die
ist schluss
ich finde es geht aus situation aber die
arcor ist so fest gespannt sein so viel
pflege und unterstützung leisten
investiert
werden
[Musik]
unterwegs spitex zentrales burgdorf
wieder miriam hat sie viel büroarbeit
gesammelt
das ganze thema ist ihm das schon
richtige großbetrieb
ach so aggressiv wie texas mississippi
wird jetzt massaker
es wertet fachgebiet abdeckt wanderwarte
tätig wie zum beispiel psychiatrie oder
wundversorgung und sich im verhältnis
rutschte günstig sagt spitex macht
gerade mal zwei prozent für seine
gesamten gesundheitskosten uns
dass miriam red mit der ärztin und krebs
rang am aphorismen einfach wie im kopf
es stetig sache die blutungsgefahr
identität des
absprachen
mit joachim otto wenn sie in die
luftröhre für ihn etwas
passiert die anbieter die sich meistens
der sehr schnell aber
nicht unbedingt schön
wie spricht man
druckt wie offen und souverän miriam mit
süchtigen themen um gott und medikament
zu ihrem klient helfert steuer bezahlen
als die angestellte ohne sie wäre das
will weg vergessen
zum glück sind aber nicht alle psyche so
schwer droemer alltäglichkeit spitex zum
beispiel im zug frankreich
noch immer schlägt ihm wieder aufwärts
mit rime auf der medal of
honor das stimmt
was passiert sind wir stehen
miriam 33 die ganze verantwortung
russland
[Musik]
bei der hypo vom emmental mit vielen
menschen noch nie wie früher nur die
großfamilie zusammen ganz anders sah sie
die stadt auf dem bauernhof wohnen drei
generationen des verbrauchers für
bezieher familie der buren betrieb
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
frau brache ist einen ski und nach ihrem
schläger fremde hilfe
jaja
nach schnaps ja die leute
halt
gute nacht schlafe gut
mit dem schnaps der merchinger steht im
alter und social bar wie verbrauchen
[Musik]
sieben jahren morde in der spitex
zentrale allem für sie am 20
der erste klientinnen und klienten
anfang
auch miriam odihr interessant frau brach
erwartet
[Musik]
und deutschland auf
die bühne dass man
noch vieles bitte später xml richtig
macht also
und da
wäre mir brache beraten auch equity
firma und bis morgen
[Musik]
in china fährt bleibt da werden ob sie
hinter und
sony spitex da war schwierig das geht
nicht gut
[Musik]
und zum schluss gibt's nur ex profi
guten morgen
[Musik]
morgen vor aufrecht sie sind hier
informiert da ist sie als babies spitex
und
die lymphdrainage strömt von der frau
die sich
ja die bäckchen
[Gelächter]
nur mehr gut das ist so wie wenn andere
so offen meinte bayer-coach und toben
und
das stimmt dass er nicht nur daran
überhaupt dir
nicht viel hochachtung vor den bug
[Gelächter]
zu hause wie anstrengend
die letzten maßnahmen kilogramm zu
verziehen
[Gelächter]
das ist
also alles gute
dankeschön
gretchen
[Gelächter]
extrem
vorschlagen dass ihr die zukunft des
spitex ein dickmacher tvo heißt miriam
mittendrin dass ich da wo ihr sind oder
ihr sind wir streben im leben das ist
mir extrem ich fahre was also will es
geht um so viel mehr als nur
medizinische behandlung sondern ich
meine du wirst jedem haus eine neue
liebesgeschichte ihnen prof das ist die
schönste moment jetzt für die
gkv wir jetzt ein kompaktes irgendwie
art fonds auf die ecke die art und weise
und für mehr schutz von stadt ist man
wie er bezieht bekommt zu den
altmeistern
verbringen jetzt noch zu dem wofür die
intergraph
ivo nie ganz von der spitex versprochen
haben
ein ehepaar hooliganszene hüsli am
waldrand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt bin immer der steht seine cds
kaufen der homo maske die aktie
sei im
organisieren gerne gesehen
[Applaus]
naja
was ich letztlich nur eine bekommen
also mein führen sie jetzt
alt
ja ja
gern
[Gelächter]
gesprochen
[Musik]
möbel schlamm die habe ich meine ich
persönlich für das jahr wählen aber ich
freue mich einfach wer übernimmt die
betreuung wenn du jetzt mitspieler die
großeltern in ältere technik laufen oder
eines problem ihnen oder wer spielbereit
sein kollege gespannt auf die niemand
gerne die kommentarspalten und von mir
gibt es für miriam und spitex team schon
mal ein viertel